la bibliothèque médicale du chum
s'apprête à quitter l'hôtel dieu sur les
tablettes presque vide
il ne reste que des périodes et
ultraspécialisés né au sous-sol du
premier hôpital de montréal
on a aussi trouvé des trésors oubliés on
a notre rêve le plus fou en 1694 et
alapage d'être voici la quatrième
édition du traiter des maladies des
femmes grosses et de celles qui sont à
clichy puis on a appuyé avec les paquets
qui nous ont été transmis lors vous donc
que c'était qu'à la première édition
datée de 1668 et avait été autorisé par
louis cas lors de la naissance à la mort
osséja qui appartenait c'était du demi
du coup légal sur la pendaison un
docteur pas devin c'est signé le 14
février 1885 à montréal et il a été
offert gracieusement à l'hôpital notre
dame
plus de 600 vieux livres de médecine
provenant des trois hôpitaux à l'origine
du chum vont être donnés à des
institutions et universités
un cadeau merveilleux pour le musée des
hospitalières
les religieuses qui à l'époque ont
commencé à bâtir la bibliothèque médical
de l'hôtel-dieu livres alors que
j'affectionne particulièrement qui est
le un des plus anciens de ski qui nous a
été donnée qui portent sur les maladies
vénériennes et l' ouvrage de 1740 la
théorie de l'époque vient rejoindre des
instruments qui ont traversé le temps et
jeter un éclairage sur les pratiques
opératoire du 19e siècle
donc on a pleins d'objets
médicaux et là on est capable avec les
volumes de pouvoir documenter ces objets
là donc de comprendre à quoi les objets
médicaux servait et en même temps de
voir l'état de la connaissance par
exemple en 1900 aujourd'hui les
périodiques dominent largement les
publications médicales
parce que les livres sont vite dépassés
en cancer ou en radiologie par exemple
il ya eu beaucoup d'avancées un livre de
radiologie de qui traite de radiologie
de 1990 on est à des années lumières au
niveau de l'imagerie médicale de ce
convoi par contre tout ce qui est
psychiatre et psychologique hawks
connaître manie santé mentale c'est plus
des domaines mon voie dé retour de
balancier de tendance on peut retrouver
dans nos collections aussi des livres
évidemment de freud donc on la base
reste toujours importante dans ces
disciplines
c'est une bibliothèque médicale du 21e
siècle qui s'installera l'an prochain
dans un nouveau bâtiment du chum à
l'emplacement même du vieil hôpital
saint luc on trouvera aussi des ouvrages
destinés aux patients
ici à nourrice des matis radio canada
montréal
[Musique]